[Música]
Bienvenidos a Francia enfoco su cita con
la actualidad francesa por las pantallas
de France 24 el gobierno de Manuel
macron acaba de presentar un nuevo
proyecto de ley de inmigración es el
texto número 21 desde 1986 la gran
novedad es que incluye un permiso de
residencia por trabajo de un año para
personas que se encuentren de manera
irregular en Francia y ejerzan un oficio
en tensión es decir donde falta mano de
obra las ongs califican este texto de
innecesario mientras que los migrantes
navegan entre la antigua ley ya
restrictiva y la incertidumbre frente a
este nuevo proyecto
las oficinas de la cimat la organización
de ayuda a los migrantes no conocen días
flojos hasta Ella llegó esta maliense
tras recibir una orden de expulsión de
territorio francés limpia casas y
oficinas y quiere saber si después de
cinco años en Francia puede al fin salir
de la sombra y conseguir un certificado
de residencia
la tarea no parece fácil trabaja con un
alias es decir los documentos de otra
persona sus nóminas de sueldo no están a
su nombre con el sistema actual solo le
queda convencer a su empleador para que
le haga un certificado de concordancia
es decir que diga que Sella la persona
que ha trabajado con él todo este tiempo
aquí le escribo que ese trámite no trae
ninguna consecuencia para el empleador y
que pueda hacerlo sin peligro para ellos
quedas abajo cuando el jefe sepa que
después de años trabajó con un documento
que no es mío no va a pensar no importa
esta mujer Es una excelente trabajadora
les da igual
y si te echan inesperadamente en 15 días
es un golpe
hay gente que pierde la cabeza
la mujer Podría quizás beneficiarse del
proyecto de ley de inmigración que
pretende regularizar extranjeros que ya
están en Francia y ejercen un oficio en
tensiones es decir donde falta mano de
obra pero el reconocimiento de los años
que ya ha trabajado sigue siendo
necesario la limpieza y ayuda a la
persona son dos oficios verdaderamente
en tensión
si el empleador se niega a hacer la
concordancia entre su identidad
verdadera y la que dio para trabajar
esas nóminas de sueldos se perderán
y Será muy Injusto verdaderamente para
alguien que trabajó tan duro
hace catorce meses que una veintena de
migrantes viven en la calle en este
polimonio Industrial del sur de París
trabajaron durante meses en esta
compañía pública de logística y reparto
contratados a través de una agencia de
trabajo temporal
sin documentación la mayoría fueron
empleados bajo una identidad falsa
cuando pidieron que los regularizaran
cosecharon para ellos el proyecto del
gobierno no es una alternativa Qué pasa
si usted luego cambia un trabajo que no
está en tensión significa que usted
pierde su residencia se quedará sin
papeles una residencia por oficio en
tensión quiere decir que usted solo
tiene derecho a trabajar en esos
trabajos es decir Usted está obligado a
hacer los trabajos que los otros no
quieren hacer aunque no quiere
nosotros queremos residencia definitiva
Libertad para todos trabajar dignamente
y vivir dignamente No pedimos nada más
una residencia No es una tarjeta para
sacar dinero del cajero automático una
fogata un té Matar el tiempo con el
celular el grupo mantiene la moral en
alto su situación es única el empleo a
través de una identidad falsa es moneda
las empresas se benefician explotando
las personas sin papeles porque le salen
menos caras
ahorran el mano de obras sobre todo en
empresas muy competitivas como la
logística como la logística
es un sistema conocido sobre todo de los
empresarios que se aprovechan de él y
conocido por el estado
al mismo tiempo hay una posición
perversa del Estado hay medio de
regularizarlos pero se les pide haber
trabajado para tener una residencia
Aunque en teoría lo tienen prohibido
pero todos saben que ellos trabajan
la batalla de estos trabajadores es
contra el tiempo esperen que su lucha de
resultados y que la llegada de un nuevo
texto no ponga más obstáculos al sueño
de una vida normal en Francia
la prefectura es el lugar donde los
migrantes tramitan sus permisos de
residencia pero son procesos muy
burocráticos por lo que el rol de las
ongs es fundamental nosotros conversamos
con fanelí caraconte secretaria general
de la cima una de estas organizaciones
[Música]
Buenos días fanellic en Francia ha
habido 21 textos o proyectos de ley
sobre inmigración desde 1986 era
necesaria una nueva ley de inmigración
en todo caso lo que no era necesario era
este proyecto de ley inscrito en una
espiral de proyectos que se suceden año
tras año y que van en la misma dirección
es decir más restricciones a los
derechos de las personas migrantes y que
son siempre construidos en la misma
filosofía que es aquella de decir que
hay que frenar la inmigración de
aquellos que consideramos indeseables en
Europa y en nuestro territorio
Ustedes han podido leer el texto Cuáles
son los pros y los contras que ustedes
se encuentran a este proyecto de ley
[Música]
principio consideré hay una medida que
podríamos haber considerado un punto
positivo la que permite regularizar a
las personas por trabajos en oficios en
tensión es decir con carencia de mano de
obra Pero y desgraciadamente Hay un pero
esta propuesta en el proyecto de ley es
muy restringida solamente compete
algunos oficios y considerar solo los
factores económicos
por ejemplo Hay personas en nuestro país
que no tienen papeles que viven de
manera precaria pero que en cambio
tienen una familia amigos una residencia
han hecho su vida aquí y que no los
vamos a regularizar hay muchas
disposiciones que van a fragilizar
también los derechos de los migrantes
por ejemplo se va a condicionar la
concesión de la tarjeta de residencia de
larga duración a la obtención de un
diploma de francés esto puede excluir a
las personas que han tenido menos
educación escolar en su vida y en su
país de origen
hay otras medidas que van a facilitar el
retiro de la residencia a las personas
que se dice no respetan los principios
de la República pero sin más explicación
nos parece muy subjetivo y también está
la reafirmación de algo que nos choca
que es lo que llamamos doble pena una
persona extranjera que cometió delitos y
que estuvo en prisión y que al salir
libre recibirá una expulsión del
territorio
Francia está entre los países europeos
que imponen más obligaciones de dejar el
territorio que cabe esperar con respecto
a esas expulsiones con este nuevo
proyecto de ley
el ministro del interior entregó varias
consignas para sistematizar la entrega
de estas obligaciones de dejar el
territorio de manera indiscriminada Hoy
hay personas que reciben una orden de
expulsión del territorio y eso no es
legal Porque por ejemplo tienen hijos
franceses Tenemos también personas a
quienes les dan estas órdenes de
expulsión y que no se pueden expulsar es
el caso de las personas de nacionalidad
afganas Siria o iraní
estamos en una cosa muy dogmática donde
se insiste en asimilar la inmigración
con la delincuencia ideas de odio y de
rechazo que vienen de la extrema derecha
y a veces de la derecha por lo tanto
debemos cambiar verdaderamente de lógica
con respecto a la cuestión migratoria
Muchas gracias fanelli por esta
entrevista con Francia 24 el ministro
del interior que esta nueva ley alejará
de Francia a los migrantes que tengan
problemas con el orden Público de hecho
este país es de los que más decreta
órdenes de expulsión Sin embargo ejecuta
apenas una ínfima parte nosotros
conversamos con una migrante salvadoreña
que dos veces ha estado en esa situación
viene el 23 de septiembre del 2019
me vine como asistente de español en
febrero del 2020 se vino lo del covid de
parte de la Academia y de París nos
dijeron que teníamos que regresarnos
antes de que se empeorara la situación
no pudimos porque las fronteras al menos
la frontera del Salvador ya estaba
cerrada y luego cuando el contrato se
terminó
la frontera de mi país Al menos todavía
seguía cerrada y trate de buscar otro
empleo fui a una panadería y
lastimosamente la panadería me dio solo
una promesa de empleo trate de ir a la
prefectura de París para tener papeles
prefectura me lo negó Y fue cuando
recibí mi primera obligación de dejar el
territorio francés ellos te mandan una
carta
diciendo que
te niegan el permiso para seguir aquí y
diciendo que tiene solo 30 días para
dejar el territorio francés bueno por
supuesto No te tienes que dejar
controlar esos 30 días que te quedan y
significa también que no puedes
presentar ningún otro otra solicitud por
un año La Academia de París me volvió a
contactar porque necesitaban asistentes
de español a causa del covid ellos
fueron los que me ayudaron a quitar esa
obligación de dejar el territorio
francés empecé a trabajar con la Academy
de París otra vez por un año más y bueno
cuando terminó mi contrato en abril otra
vez
seguí en las de buscar otro otra manera
de un salario trabajos como niñera
algunas horas en algunos restaurantes
Pero todo no declarado así como un mes
que Viaje al sur de Francia mientras iba
en el bus hicieron un control y
justamente mi pasaporte solo lo llevaba
en el teléfono una foto de mi pasaporte
me detuvieron al día siguiente me
dijeron no hay
no hay antecedentes con la policía
pero no tienes permiso para estar aquí
así que
tenemos que darte otra obligación de
dejar el territorio francés Es un estrés
estrés inmediato Porque todo lo que has
ganado aquí con tu trabajo todas las
amistades
quizás tendrás que dejarlas y regresar a
tu país tienes miedo de cualquier
control de policía me queda claro de que
no puedo salir de París Me gustaría
seguir estudiando pero para inscribirme
a una universidad tengo que regresar a
El Salvador y el problema es que si
regreso al Salvador no puedo regresar
por un año a Francia porque estoy ilegal
desde que estaba en mi país en El
Salvador me ha gustado muchísimo el
francés me empecé a enamorar de la
historia de este país todo esto es un
sueño para mí me gustaría tener un
máster en traducción Ese es mi objetivo
hacer una vida aquí y hasta aquí este
capítulo de Francia enfoco Muchas
gracias por su compañía y hasta una
próxima por las pantallas de France 24 o
en France 24.com
[Música]